tain c'est ouf comme à chaque vidéo je
me sens jamais avoir la même tête aller
bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
on va parler de star wars
ça faisait très longtemps que
j'attendais ce trailer et enfin le voilà
je pense très sincèrement que nous ne
sommes pas du tout prêt pour ce qui va
arriver décembre arrive très
dangereusement et je pense qu'il reste
au moins un trailer d'ici fin septembre
début octobre je pense je suis vraiment
très heureux d'en reparler star wars
sous forme de trois théories comme à
l'ancienne et on dirait que vous êtes
motivé aussi alors n'hésite pas à lâcher
ton plus beau pouces bleus et à activer
la cloche ne perdons pas plus de temps
et entamons les théories
bien pour ceux qui n'étaient pas au
courant j'ai fait un live avec des
abonnés ou nous avons analysé ce nouveau
trailer et il ya vraiment des choses en
tirer qu'en est-il de dark ray celle que
nous voyons à la fin du trailer avec son
dobro sabre laser est ce réellement ray
qui aurait tourné du côté obscur une
vision une soeur voyons ça ensemble tout
de suite
comme je vous l'affirmé dans ma vidéo
analyse du trailer nous ne sommes
clairement pas face à l'arrêt que nous
connaissons au point même que je ne
pense pas du tout qu'elle soit celle que
nous connaissons effectivement c'est ray
semble très robotique dans sa façon
d'agir et de regarder
contrairement à un humain lambda de plus
star wars n'en est pas à son premier
coup d'essai concernant les bandes
annonces
un petit peu aguicheuse et un petit peu
trompeuse souvenez-vous des trailer de
star wars 8 où justement nous voyons key
lorraine tendre la main à ré déchirer
sur ou doux à se trouver sa place dans
l'histoire
alors le cas de ré sombrant dans le côté
obscur n'est tout de même pas à négliger
car justement c'était déjà présent dans
star wars 8 et c'est un sacré fantasmes
des fans mais il ne faut pas faire de
conclusions trop rapides et chez disney
ils savent comment extrapoler un détail
revenons sur le trailer déjà je ne sais
pas si vous l'aviez remarqué mais c'est
très du côté obscur est face à quelqu'un
dans le trailer et je suis prêt à mettre
ma main à couper qu'il s'agit de l'arrêt
que nous connaissons alors jamais ne pas
me baser sur de gros arguments mais ne
vous inquiétez pas ça pourquoi je pense
qu'il s'agit d'une fausse ray face à
l'arrêt que nous connaissons j'aimerais
que nous nous tournions vers star war 5
pour l'expliquer avec une scène très
précises si vous vous rappelez bien luc
par sur dagobah pour y trouver yoda ce
dernier le formera pour devenir un jedi
et vaincre l'empereur et dark vador
cependant il y au dha suspecte beaucoup
de colère et d'impatience en luc et le
testerin à un moment donné yoda en voit
lui dans un endroit très propice au côté
obscur et ce dernier se retrouve face à
une illusion de lui même déguisé en dark
vador dans star wars 9 nous savons que
mark hamill sera de retour pour rejouer
luc et comme affirmé dans star wars 8 à
kayes lorraine ce dernier reviendra le
hanter et formera ray pour devenir là
dernière des jedi fait souligné par les
deux trailer consécutif
affirmant que 1000 années de générations
vivent en ré qu'elle a terminé son
apprentissage
nous savons que yoda est donc toujours
présent par rapport à l'épisode 8 et 6
nuls doit former rey à devenir la
dernière des jedi il reproduira
forcément l'enseignement que yoda lui a
donné à l'époque ce qui est d'ailleurs
pertinent à ce sujet et qui me conforte
dans l'idée d'une illusion de ré et que
l'udc semble très méfiant à l'idée de
former ray dans le côté lumineux tout
comme yoda l'était à l'époque pour l'udc
et c'était obi wan qui appuyait le jeune
apprenti pour convaincre
yoda d'en faire un jedi et dans star
wars 8 yoda reprend ce rôle qu'obi wan
avait à l'époque rey doit finir sa
formation elle est la dernière des jedi
et pour ce faire
yoda et luc doivent savoir ce qu'il y a
dans le coeur de retz le schéma est
exactement le même qu'à l'époque de
l'épisode 5
preuve encore une fois avec
l'entraînement dorée qui serait sur ce
qui semble être la lune forestière
d'andorre
un lieu chargé d'histoire dans la
première trilogie le lieu de bataille
finale de l'épisode 6
et bizarrement nous sommes à la fin de
la nouvelle trilogie du 7 8 9
ray semble d'ailleurs s'entraîner avec
un engin similaire à ce que l'udc avait
à l'époque
jj abrams aime beaucoup s'inspirer de la
première trilogie
comme il nous l'avait montré avec star
wars 7 et étant chargé de s'occuper de
star wars 9
nous retrouvons le même schéma
d'entraînement jedi qu'avec luc à son
époque
pour aller un peu plus dans le détail
bien que les thrillers son vendeur
il reste tout de même plein de mystères
et de détail important déjà avant
l'apparition de rain nous avons le son
d'un bruit fantomatique horrifique avec
le soufflement de dark vador
puis quand à recréer apparaît nous la
voyons équipé d'une bague sur l'index
gauche ceci fait clairement référence à
snow qu'avec la bac contenant un morceau
d'obsidienne du château de dark vador
puis après nous terminons sur le thème
de ré une octave plus bas pour souligner
le côté obscur et tragique du moment
tous ces détails indiquent clairement
pour moi que ray serait face à la
représentation d'elle-même dans le côté
obscur avec un double sabre faisant
référence à son bâton qui est son arme
dans l'épisode 7
bien évidemment tout ce que j'affirme
n'est qu'une interprétation personnelle
à vous de partager votre propre avis sur
la question dans les commentaires
[Musique]
toutes ces vieilles choses soit cet art
nous entrons dans le cas le plus
philosophique et le plus mystérieux de
ce star wars 9 et quelque chose me
chiffonne avec les deux trailer qui nous
ont été présentés sur l'opus finale de
star wars
bien évidemment tout ne sera pas montré
avec les trailer et les mystères sont de
plus en plus présents preuve avec les
chevaliers de rennes toujours pas montré
bien qu'il soit présent dans ce dernier
opus mais à qui s'adresse réellement le
titre du film aurait serait-elle
vraiment une skywalker comme soupçonné
avec ce qui a été montré une sorte d'élu
de la nouvelle trilogie
ou bien est-ce que kyle aurait n'aura un
impact plus important qu'on le pense
c'est ça la chose qui m'interroge
carrie lorraine l'élément principal
marketing de star wars 7 et le supprime
leader autoproclamé de l'épisode 8 est
totalement mis de côté dans les trailer
de star wars 9
pourquoi cela pourquoi le mettre de côté
pour mettre en avant rey et le retour de
l'empereur
car c'est que disney nous cache quelque
chose pour qu'on s'attende le moins
possible à une action qui pourrait
renverser toute l'histoire et c'est ce
qui a été intégrée dans ces nouveaux
fils le conflit chez veine est présent
depuis l'opus 7 et ce n'est un secret
pour personne
sa liaison avec ray est bien réel est
toujours d'actualité
les deux personnages sont connectés et
seront amenés à se revoir mais il faut
essayer de voir plus loin que ce que
nous avons actuellement entre les mains
l'héritage des jedi est un échec
l'udc l'a très bien souligner mais pas
seulement lui aussi qu à l oreille bien
qu'ils soient extrêmes dans ses actes et
ses propos qu'elle aurait n'affirme que
toutes ces vieilles choses doivent
s'éteindre snoeck skywalker etc
malgré son côté obscur cai lorraine est
d'accord avec lui que les jedi doivent
s'éteindre ainsi que les sites
si star wars doit se terminer réellement
avec l'épisode 9
il faut que les jedi et les sith
n'existe plus mais que seuls des
utilisateurs de la force existe voilà ma
vision qu'a lorraine est beaucoup trop
sous-estimé pour la fin de la saga
et comme il a été montré palpatine est
de retour ray écailles lorraine depuis
le début de la nouvelle trilogie ont
toujours été mis en confrontation de par
l'apprentissage catherine ouest nok
à peine solo et ré par le biais des
légendes jedi et luke skywalker
néanmoins comme déclarés par les acteurs
eux-mêmes la relation entre ray etc est
lorraine n'est vraiment pas anodine est
très compliqué palpatine étant au final
de retour enfin c'est pas trop pour le
moment rien ne nous dit que kay lorraine
se rangerait de son côté car comme
affirmé qu alors elle souhaite détruire
toutes ces anciennes chose est de par
son ego et son ambition il veut le
pouvoir si palpatine est réellement de
retour il pourrait bien être une menace
plus qu'autre chose pour le nouveau
supprimé leader ce que je veux dire
c'est que ray kay lorraine seront
toujours comme des équivalents des
rivaux mais l'udc dans l'apprentissage
devrait lui a inculqué que le temps des
jedi était venu et kayes lorraine a
vaincu snoeck et souhaite stopper tout
ce qui a toujours été
palpatine et l'origine des problèmes en
quelque sorte de toute la saga des films
de star wars et se pourrait que ben &
ress s'unissent pour vaincre ce qu'il
reste de l'empereur et ramenez-les
équilibre une fois pour toutes
soit la fin des jedi et des sites pour
laisser un monde meilleur
néanmoins malgré cette union caille
lorraine reste trop dans ses idéaux et
tenterait de prendre le pouvoir
pourrait-il revenir du bon côté comme
dark vador dans l'épisode ultime de la
première trilogie
ou pas dans tous les cas elle affiche
promotionnelle de star wars 9 et pleine
de sens une fois de plus près et calais
lorraine sont de nouveau mis en
confrontation l'un contre l'autre et
cette fois ci devant les débris de
l'étoile de la mort et si justement il
était temps pour les deux protagonistes
qu'ils ne soient pas ennemis mais plutôt
des alliés et qui à eux deux ils peuvent
conclure l'histoire
palpatine en regard de haut le combat
attentivement et semble liée aux deux
personnages
[Musique]
et l'ironie il avait vaincu la mort pour
les autres mais la sienne n'a pas su
l'éviter s'il ya bien une chose que je
trouve importantes dans les thrillers
qui nous ont été montrés c'est la
représentation de palpatine
ce dernier est bel et bien présent dans
star wars 9 de part la présence de
l'acteur son rire dans le premier
trailer et sa voix dans le second mais
nous ne voyons jamais sidious
physiquement nous ne l'avons toujours
pas vu est ce que ça veut dire que
disney souhaite cacher quelque chose que
représente au final dark sidious et quel
sera son rôle
impliquer de nouveau dark sidious dans
la nouvelle trilogie un pic forcément
quelque chose de lourd et surtout
d'obscurs effectivement en snacks et
quelle reine ne sont pas des sites mais
des adeptes du côté obscur sidious et
l'empereur avec un grand e
le seigneur sith par excellence est l'un
des plus grands manipulateurs de la
galaxie on ne peut pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi avec palpatine
et si jj abrams la ramener dans cette
nouvelle trilogie c'est qu'il a
forcément quelque chose derrière la tête
il se pourrait que sidious soit derrière
tout ce qu'il se passe dans la nouvelle
trilogie de part son retour l'élément de
toutes les vérités cachées
sinon à quoi servirait de ramener ce
personnage déjà par rapport à kayes
lorraine sidious est un très grand
manipulateur et il ya de fortes chances
qu'il ait un rapport avec ce look de
près ou de loin étant un grand
manipulateur et comme il l'avait fait
khanaqinne pour le comte dooku palpatine
aurait pu encourager et aider cas
lorraine à prendre le pouvoir et tu es
snoeck qui au final n'était pas si
puissant qu'on aurait pu le penser mais
il se pourrait que ce soit un simple
coup stratégique de 6,12 pour s'amener
de nouveaux pouvoirs
effectivement pourquoi palpatine
prendrait-il le risque de se fier de
nouveau à un nouvel apprenti un nouveau
skywalker déchiré lui aussi dans ses
pensées
c'est ce qui lui coûta la vie à l'époque
où dark vador était son allié et comme
je vous l'affirmé dans une précédente
vidéo palpatine serai présent pour semer
la zizanie entre les derniers
utilisateurs de la force et que
justement ce ne soit pas ce nokia qui
est mis en contact les écailles lorraine
mais bien sidious le poster du nouveau
film accentue énormément cette idée ou
ray kay lorraine sont de nouveau en face
à face tandis que papa tine regarde en
haut sans que personne ne puisse le voir
comme s'il avait toujours été là
à observer et potentiellement en tirer
les ficelles pour être au fait tout ça
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la flotte
impériale présente dans le trailer
si cette flotte est présente c'est
qu'elle a une utilité et il est certain
que cai lorraine va vouloir sont
appropriés mais comment caille lorraine
pourrait être au courant qu'une telle
flotte soit toujours présente des années
après star wars 6 et bien par le biais
du sidious évidemment il est presque
évident d'affirmer que cai lorraine et
sidious est un rapport de près ou de
loin mais palpatine ne refera pas la
même erreur et se servirait de calais
lorraine simplement de façon utilitaire
mais un autre retour serait ultra
pertinent pour la fin de la série car
oui nous sommes à la fin normalement
ultime de la saga et nous savons que jj
abrams aime beaucoup les références aux
anciens star wars comme il le fit avec
star wars set je garde personnellement
en tête un potentiel retour d'anakin en
force ghost et peut-être obi wan
pourquoi cela star wars ci s'est
terminée avec le retour danakil en
fantôme de la force aux côtés d'obi wan
il est évident que star wars neuf
pourrait se finir sur ce genre de plan
avec ray face à luke et yoda au minimum
elle semble d'ailleurs être déjà sur
endor la lune de l'épisode 6 déjà lu
qu'affirme dans le premier trailer qu'on
ne disparaît jamais réellement
et bizarrement sidious est de retour
yoda est toujours présent en tant que
fantôme
alors pourquoi pas anakin ou encore
obi-wan la voix d'obi wan et est
présente dans la vision de ré dans star
wars 7 qui disait tes premiers pas comme
s'il connaissait ray enfants nous savons
également que john christensen l'acteur
d'anakin sera présent à la fa knicks
salt lake comic con venture cette
présence pourrait indiquer un potentiel
retour dans star wars neuf comme avec
l'acteur de palpatine au moment de
dévoiler le premier trailer de l'opus 9
le retour d'anne est une permettrait
d'éclairer certaines choses et mettre en
lumière le réel questionnement de kay
lorraine qui semble toujours en
possession du casque de son grand-père
dans le dernier trailer
il est celui qui connaît le mieux 'le
patine à l'heure actuelle et pourrait
guider rey a trouvé sa véritable place
ainsi que potentiellement son identité
voilà en tout cas ce que j'ai à dire sur
star wars 9
je ne suis pas à l'abri de vous refaire
1,3 théorie d'ici le prochain trailer
dans tous les cas on reparlera sur de
star wars 9 dec le film sera sorti
si la vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à lâcher votre plus gros
pouce bleus et à me dire en commentaire
vos idées concernant ce dernier opus je
suis également sur instagram twitter et
youtube
c'était argot rock et que le lion's soit
avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]